This
week we are creating a better opportunity for the horse. The exercise
is to develop awareness of where the horse is landing his step and the
easiest way to do this is with obstacles. So we have this horse walking over
cavalettes. We want the same distance of step on the takeoff of the cavalette and
the landing. When we provide the horse with this greater opportunity there's a
greater chance of success. So in slow motion here you can see when he steps
perfectly even on both sides his step does not interfere with the cavalette
and when he gets too close or too far away he makes up a different solution to
solve the problem either brushing the cavalette or hopping over it
inappropriately for the sake of the exercise at the walk. I would encourage
you to do this at the walk a lot with your horses it's such a great exercise
for joints and for their brain to slow things down and solve the problems in
time. Start with the cavalettes on the lowest setting until your horse gets
more comfortable move it up as they get more confident. Level two is a course of
pulls on the ground. This is a simplified 21 foot one stride and a nine foot bounce
inside a course. When you're riding through it make sure that you're fair
about how the distance that you get to each pole. If you get a shorter distance
understand that the horse may not be able to solve the problem in the pace
that he's already in. For example if the horse is in trot he may want to walk or
accelerate to try and make up for that flaw and understand where that's coming
from and why it might have happened before you try and correct it correct
yourself. So here we have a very green horse that's relatively not coordinated
yet he is feeling confident in the trot to adjust his distances in this trot
pole course and you can see he's moving his body around up and down with his
head moving his hind legs forward and back to try and solve all these problems.
It's very important as a trainer as a rider as the coach to your horse that
you have an understanding of why they're making those adjustments. So here in the
canter of course with a horse that is young not coordinated or maybe it's
their first time they're bound to make mistakes throughout their course or try
and solve problems in a way that you may not expect. So if you have an
understanding of why they may have calculated the math that way then you
are more likely to build a partnership with the horse and their interest in
seeking your opinion before and after obstacles or in general in your flat
work is more likely. The biggest tip I can give you here is to keep praising
them for solving problems not just looking pretty. If we break down this
course of this younger horse in the canter you can see why he might be
making some of these decisions. When he gets to a short place that those green
poles he decides to canter or even tranter through which is a mix of the
trot in the canter that young horses sometimes do. So again there he decides
to split and move to the trot. So as a rider it's my job to support him and be
okay with that until still tell him that he's a good boy for solving the problem.
Adjust your priorities. So there is a very good example of the perfect
situation giving him the best result so this young maybe not coordinated horse
can still get a beautiful lead change if we give him the best opportunity for it.
And the other opportunities where he's learning to control his step and may
need to trot or change his shape or balance are opportunities for him to
learn and develop skills inside his own body. There we have a perfect distance.
Later on when the horse is more advanced and can jump you can see them making
their own adjustments looking into the math and having a reciprocating
relationship with you when you're both deciding where to place the legs. You see
the ears go up he sits back on the hind legs and he's making adjustments so that
he's in the right spot at the right time up to his preference.
Remember the main goal is to make the same distance happen on either side of
the obstacle.